je suis un enfant de Canal+ j'ai écrit
pour les nuls pour les pour Groland pour
h avant de jouer dans le Caméra Café
donc j'ai connu une grande liberté
d'expression et donc j'avais envie de
parler de tous les sujets qui pouvaient
fâcher dans notre société et on
s'aperçoit qu'on peut rigoler absolument
de tout seul aujourd'hui oui sur scène
c'est sûr à la télévision c'est devenu
plus problématique parce qu'aujourd'hui
si vous dites que vous êtes contre les
moustiques et à une association qui va
vous dire c'est dégueulasse
oui aujourd'hui on est sur un consensus
pour un consensus pour les punaises de
lit ça c'est bon les punaises de lit
tout le monde est contre les punaises de
lit mais pour les moustiques il y a
challenge donc voilà
espèces qui arrivent les moustiques on
s'en sort plus c'est
on peut plus tout on peut pas tout dire
à la télé Sophie aujourd'hui on peut
assis ici en fait
moi je considère que la télévision c'est
comme la vie voilà faut être sans langue
de bois on peut tout dire après si on
blesse les gens si on vexe les gens si
on fait du mal ça c'est autre chose donc
moi j'essaie de tout dire avec empathie
ça me concerne 7 fois ma langue dans la
bouche avant de dire quelque chose et
j'ai appris quelque chose aussi à
travers Twitter depuis il y a 5-6 ans
j'avais fait une critique sur une
émission de télévision ça m'est revenu
en boomerang et depuis ce jour-là je me
dis plus jamais je dis quelque chose de
négatif sur les réseaux sociaux là pour
valoriser les choses et depuis je suis
extrêmement tranquille merci la vie
la bienveillance très importante la
bienveillance sur des conditions un
petit mot sur vos débuts 87 vous
commencez à écrire avec pour Canal on
est nulle
d'enfance de Dominique Farrugia que je
suis créatif dans la publicité où je me
fais suer pour pas dire chier en fait et
donc voilà et j'écrivais la qualité de
la passion la passion de la qualité donc
je tournais vraiment en boucle et quand
ils m'ont proposé de de d'écrire pour
eux j'ai l'impression d'être rentré dans
la caverne d'Ali Baba et j'ai jamais
voulu en ressortir en fait parce que
c'est trop bien de dire des conneries et
d'être payé pour il y a beaucoup de
choses qui étaient écrites à l'époque
mais aussi beaucoup de happening des
choses qui se décidaient vraiment à la
dernière minute oui mais tout était x
assez écrit assez bordé en fait l'humour
ça nécessite la part d'improvisation
c'est qu'on a travaillé avant et du coup
vous aviez fait les fausses pubs comme
j'ai fait j'ai fait pas mal de fausses
qui passerait plus aujourd'hui à la
télévision mais vous pouvez regardez sur
YouTube sur le sur les sur les DVD mais
voilà c'était c'était une époque qui
était bénie et contrairement à ce que ce
qu'on peut penser on faisait attention à
ce qu'on disait mais on n'était pas la
censure on chaque artiste ou chaque
auteur s'auto-censure parce qu'il n'a
pas envie de faire de peine on a juste
envie de faire de se marrer par moment
les gens comprennent pas le deuxième
degré et il manque de discernement et de
recul mais ça on peut rien faire pour
eux vous avez aussi coécrit la série H
oui absolument qu'on a tourné ici
ça s'appelle la Factory s'ils sont les
studios canal à Boulogne-Billancourt et
vous allez tourner h ici j'ai écrit un
tiers de la série avec mes camarades pas
moi tout seul mais avec Jean-Paul
battany Bruno Nicolini qui est Bénabar
et puis Fred Proust et puis Jean Gréco
etc j'aime citer des auteurs parce qu'on
ils sont jamais vraiment cités c'est un
moment merveilleux de ma vie incroyable
ça évidemment Eric et Ramzy Jamel
Debbouze alors il paraît que c'était
l'enfer parce que tout pouvait changer à
la dernière minute donc
il y a même des épisodes quand on les a
vu ils ont fait le contraire de ce qu'on
avait écrit mais comme ils avaient fait
marrer les gens personne avait osé leur
dire les gars voulaient pas vous calmer
un peu donc voilà mais c'est des belles
surprises c'est surtout des très belles
rencontres c'est la première c'est comme
française tournée en public je crois en
plus absolument absolument à
l'américaine entre guillemets est-ce
qu'on fonction des réactions du public
vous
écrivez absolument et surtout en fait
Djamel et Ricky Ramzi sont des
improvisateurs de génie donc vous leur
donnez un canevas et après eux ils le
tricote c'est incroyable mais c'est pas
mal ça et vous adaptez évidemment au
dernier moment bon c'était et c'était un
bel exercice effectivement et puis le
beau souvenir c'est sa cartonné
ça s'est arrêté parce que je pense qu'à
un moment il y avait plus le jus
Jamel avec d'autres choses à faire aussi
et puis c'était ils étaient pris par le
le cinéma la Tour Infernale jamais elle
sortait de Amélie Poulain etc donc ils
étaient pris dans un élan de faire de
Jamel a fait en même temps que H Obélix
le enfin le client mission Cléopâtre de
Chabat donc c'était vraiment vraiment
incroyable et je pense qu'ils ont été
happés ils sont dit et puis le cinéma ça
reste quand même le cinéma c'est presque
et on mélange pas le cinéma la télé
maintenant maintenant aujourd'hui tout
le monde fait des séries etc mais il y a
20 ans qu'on prenait déjà pas pourquoi
c'était cloisonné aujourd'hui c'est
totalement décloisonné d'ailleurs il y a
Jamel qui prépare le tournage d'une
nouvelle sitcom pour Canal+ qui va
rentrer un tournage en octobre et vous
appeler ça s'appelait terminale ça se
passe dans un des cours d'aéroport non
non non je suis au courant mais il m'a
pas appelé c'est pas grave
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
5 millions de téléspectateurs quasiment
tous les soirs
je n'ai pas changé voilà vous c'était
diffusé 2000 en 2004 570 épisodes voici
ça mais c'est record d'audience
quasiment à 6 millions de films au
cinéma et pareil là aussi ça s'arrête
alors que c'est génial ça c'est
pareil
le bureau oui mais en fait si au départ
on restait on dépassait les budgets en
fait parce qu'on était en heures sup et
puis à la fin à 17h on faisait deux
prises qui étaient vraiment très bonnes
et ont à 18h on était chez nous et Ivan
et Bruno sont dit on est trop dans des
chaussons on va ça on va on va perdre le
l'influx de Caméra Café l'envie de le
faire donc mieux vaut qu'on s'arrête et
ils ont très bien fait parce que quand
on a fait les 20 ans de Caméra Café non
seulement on a cartonné mais on a
récupéré toute l'énergie et tout était
intégralement là à nouveau et l'envie de
faire marrer c'est assez rare c'était
énorme une bonne tête de vainqueur
quand on est auteur comme ça comme vous
de se retrouver justement devant la
caméra c'est qu'est-ce qui est le mieux
en fait qu'est-ce qui est le plus sympa
qu'est-ce que de faire les deux devant
d'être à l'écriture et de jouer c'était
jouissif ils vont et Bruno m'appelaient
monsieur plus c'est à dire que sur le
plateau je leur ai rajouté toujours des
vannes quand ça allaiter ça on garde et
quand ça lui faisait pareil non mais ça
c'est pas crédible mais en fait c'est
parce que ça les faisait pas rire mais
ça a été un grand grand kiff de faire
Caméra Café et surtout ça faisait 6 ans
que on se le prenait dans la figure et
quand ça a démarré ça a été incroyable
et mais ce qui est dingue c'est qu'il y
a des Sylvain en Italie en Irlande enfin
voilà il y a mon père
dans 60 pays c'est un truc et aussi
exactement ça a été adapté au cinéma
pareil un gros succès c'est là où ça a
été un peu tendu avec Bruno Solo non
mais c'est terminé tout ça on a eu un
petit différent et voilà et la preuve
j'ai refait j'ai refait les 20 ans de
Caméra Café on a beaucoup rigolé et on
s'aime beaucoup
une suite vous conseille une suite c'est
une suite est possible on peut revoir on
a fait les 20 ans de Caméra Café qui ont
cartonné on s'est fait aussi cartonner
par la presse ah bon oui parce qu'ils
ont
la presse
il y avait un truc que j'adorais c'était
une machine à remonter le temps voyez
les 20 ans de ce qui s'était passé de
Caméra Café Yves Bruno qui est un
syndicaliste de gauche sur l'affaire DSK
le défendait en disant que c'était un
homme qui aimait les femmes et qui et
que c'était certainement un coup de
Sarkozy donc il était là et il y avait
Yvan en Jean-Claude qui arrivait ah bah
ça c'est les américains ils sont jaloux
de la séduction à la française ce qui me
faisait moi crever de rire parce que
voilà et on s'est fait cartonner en
disant qu'on était sexiste qu'on
défendait les bons et c'est pas très
grave mais je pense que Bruno ça l'a un
petit peu échaudé et aujourd'hui moi je
referai bien les 20 ans de Caméra Café
tous les ans en fait sur une
rétrospective ce serait vraiment bien
mais j'ai pas l'impression que ça en
prenne le chemin et puis contrairement à
ce que ce qu'on peut penser c'est Caméra
Café c'est une vraie chorégraphie c'est
à dire que les deux personnes qui
parlent devant si derrière les gens
circuitent ou passent un peu après ou un
peu avant faut refaire la prise on
imagine pas que c'est une chorégraphie
un travail de dingue à la télé
rose vous connaissez Caméra Café alors
je sais plus je crois que je devais
avoir 7 ans ouais c'est pas trop la
génération
j'aurais pu faire genre ouais mais en
vrai
ce que je propose moi dans un instant le
Zap TV de cette